we want to talk about an important issue
happening right here in town the rise of
fentanyl in las vegas
jamie ross the executive director at pac
coalition is joining us to tell more hey
jamie how are you
doing well how are you i can't complain
but i do want to talk about what's
happening right now with the opioid
crisis
in las vegas so unfortunately we are
seeing a rise in
fentanyl overdoses um the first
uh time i think anyone heard about
opioids was when we were talking about
prescription opioids
uh and we did a really good job of
changing the laws and changing the
social norms around prescription opioids
uh and then so we saw those numbers go
down and then we saw the heroin numbers
go up and we've worked really hard
for the heroin numbers to go down and
now
unfortunately what we're seeing is
fentanyl
numbers and fentanyl overdoses go up
significantly
so what is what is fentanyl and then why
is it so dangerous
so fentanyl is uh it's a synthetic
opioid drug
so think prescription opioids like
oxycontin and
percocet and then but it is
50 times more powerful than heroin uh
and
so the issue is what we're seeing is
it's coming across the border in pressed
pills
that look a lot like oxycontin percocet
etc and they're being sold on the black
market and of course there is
no quality control whatsoever and with
no quality control you don't know what
you're getting
and what we know about fentanyl is
it is an incredibly dangerous drug um
and it's the difference between trying
to smuggle
over an entire salt shaker versus a
couple of grains of salt
and we've got less than 30 seconds here
i do want to ask a person talk about
narcan
what is narcan and how is this involved
with fentanyl
so narcan is an overdose reversal drug
uh and the important thing about narcan
is
if you suspect an opioid overdose you
can give
narcan with almost no side effects but
you also have to call 9-1-1 that's the
most important thing
is call 9-1-1 and if you need access to
narcan
uh please visit our website which is
drug free las vegas dot org
and you can access anywhere to get free
narcan
in all of nevada super helpful stuff
jamie thank you so much for joining us
for more information
call pac coalition at 702 582-pac
or find them online at
drugfreelasvegas.org